God please let me survive this fall I
still have to lose my virginity
Colton takes a leap of faith heading
into hometowns he's about to my family
asking some skeptical fathers for their
blessing Colton wow man you're laying it
on me are you ready to get married are
you at that maturity level in your mind
that blows me away a little bit and
reciprocating feelings of falling in
love with some of the remaining four
women
I'm hospital
I'm falling in love with you
however Colton did end up getting every
father's blessing but Cassie's that
would be a premature blessing who also
still hasn't said she's falling for him
part of me thinks like I could be
calling enough attention but I don't
want to say it
and ultimately sent frontrunner Kaelyn
home with a tearful goodbye I'm fairly
confetti
[Music]
et spoke with Colton in January where he
spoke about making the tough decisions
man I think coming in you know you know
saying like hey I am ready you know I'm
ready for this bring it on I thought I
had it all figured out and let me tell
you what that was the last thing that I
had it I did not have it all figured out
and I think that's okay
you don't have to be this perfect person
to you know find love you don't have to
be this like shiny polished well-spoken
guy because at times yes I might seem
like that times like even right now like
I enjoyed this part of it you know I've
grown up in the industry with having to
do interviews and I think sometimes I
might come off as disingenuous and stuff
but I think just realizing hey just stay
true to who you are and you know make
the decisions you need to make in the
moment
[Music]